[Applause]
on October 7 Brazilian voters went to
the polls to choose a new president in
Congress you know one of those
complicated and polarizing elections in
that country's history gyre bolson ro
and Fernando Haddad have advanced to the
second round bowls and arrows strong
finish falling just short of a first
round victory stunned the country's
political class his tough talk resonated
with many voters who are fed up with
widespread political corruption and
staggering crime rates Haddad is the
stand-in for former president Lula da
Silva although his big government
message resonates with the country's
poor the Workers Party took a beating in
the first round
economic growth is sluggish corruption
scandals of fuel cynicism murder rates
six times that of the United States our
security crisis in this campaign has
polarized public opinion ball Janeiro
has the edge but Haddad can appeal to
millions of voters who did not
participate in the first round both will
try to make the case before the October
20th runoff that he's the man who can
put Raziel house in order
what does the future hold for Brazil let
us know in your comments and let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI
[Music]